bonjour à tous les deux merci beaucoup
d'être en direct avec nous ce matin sur
rtl france pour débattre évidemment du
ralliement de nicolas bay à moins de
deux mois du premier tour
une réaction une réaction évidemment
valentin belli et emmanuelle guerry pour
commencer
oui déjà bonjour
alors effectivement on puisse poser la
question pourquoi ce départ là
maintenant
j'allais dire que
certains partent pour des raisons
personnelles peut-être que il avait
envie d'avoir des responsabilités durant
cette campagne présidentielle à bord ils
les ont pas vus alors qu'ils te quitte
le mouvement
qu'elle considère comme ans c'est pas le
premier et on sent que c'est que c'est
quand même une tendance
alors c'est ce que je vous disais moi je
je considère ce que j'allais dire moi je
vais dire que la politique c'est l'école
de l'humilité et puis quand on
appartient à un mouvement se doit d'être
d'être fidèle voilà c'est un principe
fondamental en politique donc là ça
s'apparente plutôt à dû à du sabotage
je considère c'est ce que vous pensez
alors il ya eu 7 cette excuse ne veut
dire que il avait espionné le parti pour
le compte de la reconquête s'est avéré
mais écoutez ici si c'est le cas c'est
très grave quand on appartient quand je
dis à un moment on lui doit respect
fidélité on travaille pas pour le camp
j'ai dit en en face alors pour la
reconquête évidemment c'est une nouvelle
prise de guerre c'est celui d'hier
valentin valentin déry votre votre
réaction à vous
bonjour tout d'abord est évidemment
c'est une très bonne prise c'est une un
ralliement qui ce qui s'ajoute à plein
d'autres notamment un suivi de stéphane
ravier qui nous a rejoints très
récemment et aurait été un petit peu
aussi pour les mêmes raisons parce que
comme gilbert collard comme d'auto et
rennes comme beaucoup de militants ils
se rendent compte que bah en fait le rnd
c'est une impasse et en fait marine le
pen elle va encore perdre si on sait de
la soutiennent et en réalité quand
j'entends le fait que
il cherche personne qui chercherait des
places etc enfin nicolas bay était quand
même porte parole dans la campagne il
est député européen etc enfin je veux
dire qu'il cherche pas une place il a
juste posé une question comme d'ailleurs
comme stéphane ravier il a des goûts ce
serait peut-être bien de laisser une
certaine liberté aux expressions et
direct c'est la sanction a été ccao mais
rennes c'est à dire que les rênes d'un
parti qui laisse aucune liberté ni à ses
militants ni de ses cadres c'est une
sorte de parti stalinien un petit peu
donc en réalité marine le pen elle a
entre à 2 de creuser elle-même sa
défaite en fait elle pousse les gens à
la partie aurait forcément nous on a
dans la rubrique est qu'on est dans un
esprit de rassemblement au rassemblement
avec une telle r d vous les anciens
élèves mouvement conservateur via le sel
ni paix aussi qu'il ne l'a rejoint mais
aussi des gens d'url également voilà le
but c'est vraiment de rassembler des
gens aussi qui sont qui ont adhéré
jamais à aucun parti qui n'avait jamais
souhaité eu aucun candidat les
abstentionnistes le but c'est de faire
un rassemblement très large puisque
c'est seulement de cette façon là qu'on
peut gagner en temps l'union des droites
on peut il gagner face à emmanuel macron
emmanuelle guerry une réaction alors
est-ce que vous n'êtes aligne un évident
mais je j'entends cela
évidemment que le rassemblement chez
nous puisque nous rassemblons étaient
tous les français qui viennent de gauche
ou de droite et j'entendais mon
interlocuteur dira que voter marine le
pen se serait s'assurer d'une défaite
coûté jusqu'ici les sondages nous
portent parfois jusqu'à 40 6% au 2e tour
moi je dirais plutôt que ne pas voter
marine le pen 6 assurer le retour de dvd
macro dès le mois d'avril donc en cela
la grille et de candidature de monsieur
zemmour
j'allais dire peut ressembler à une
sorte de gardien du mc ronis m'en fait
finalement donc non je pense
qu'effectivement le rationnement des
français et c'est bien chez nous
pouvons pas faire l'union de la droite
ou de la droite nous voulons rassembler
les français alors à moins de deux mois
de ce premier tour on va parler un peu
des sondages c'est la première fois
qu'aucun candidat de droite ne se
démarque vraiment les trois candidats
sont toujours au coude à coude on va
peut-être voir ce sondage à l'antenne la
dynamique est tout de même dans l'est
dans le sens d'eric zemmour et la gauche
aussi à une certaine dynamique avec une
progression de jean-luc mélenchon et
fabien roussel emmanuel macron lui
baissent de 2,3 points valentin de lely
une réaction
évidemment on voit la dynamique honda
dépasser au moins de trois mois cent
mille adhérents c'est du jamais vu ça
fait très longtemps qu'on a pas vu ça au
moins trente ou quarante ans peut-être à
la création du rer on voit avec tous les
tous les ralliements qu'il ya là on voit
également les meetings qui font qu'ils
sont totalement rempli on voit également
les performances d'eric zemmour ce soit
sur son programme et il sort de
notamment là il est ressorti très
récemment un programme sur les flux
numériques question la truite saumonée
et il est novateur il est dans vraiment
qu'il soit sur son programme et une très
forte dynamique sur les ralliements sur
son parti dans les meetings sur les
médias partout on était eric zemmour
c'est le centre de la campagne
présidentielle aujourd'hui si elle ne
compagne de seal et le pense et
commencent à s'intéresser à la campagne
potentiel c'est un peu grâce à eric
zemmour ça qui est très intéressant
marine le pen néanmoins se maintient on
se maintient bien emmanuelle guerry
elle qu'elle conserve elle conserve sa
place est toujours que vous l'aviez dit
sa bonne place en tout cas en cas de
second tour face à emmanuel macron
effectivement j'insiste sur ce point
vis-à-vis de mon à la tortue
marine le pen est la seule capacité je
le répète à s'imposer au 2e tour face à
emmanuel macron c'est une réalité donc
en cela la candidature zemmour ne fait
là la freiner au premier tour
c'est une réalité c'est comme ça alors
on a vu aussi à eric zemmour annoncé que
marion maréchal sera son premier
ministre s'il est élu mais qu'elle doit
faire campagne avec lui c'est la
condition valente et embellit vous
pensez que c'est ce serait possible ce
ralliement
je pense en effet que c'est possible
c'est très simple eric zemmour arrive à
rassembler marion maréchal a déjà émis
j'ai envie dire un avis positif sur la
candidature d'eric zemmour il a
d'ailleurs dit que l amérique et ne
soutiendrait pas marine le pen ou dans
cette campagne
oui c'est quelque chose qui est possible
aujourd'hui elle n'a pas pris de
décision mais comme on peut le voir si
la dynamique s'accentue s'accélère
encore chez eric zemmour est évidemment
on l'aura les rois ce moment on va se
faire derrière eric zemmour emmanuelle
guerry ce serait vraiment un coup dur si
c'était le cas non
alors là on parle de choses qu'on ne
maîtrise pas en réalité je vous la donne
si la politique fiction l'huile sur la
version cc jamais venu effectivement si
jamais venu donc seule marion maréchal
prendra une décision moi je ne suis pas
dans les secrets je vais dire de
éventuel ralliement avec les émaux
mais encore une fois on fait la petite
fiction là donc
laissons un petit peu là la campagne
prend place réellement parlant de sujets
concrets
parlons du confort d'achat parlons de
notre sécurité parlons de notre
civilisation
mais là c'est la petite fille sur moi
c'est pas forcément dire ma tasse de thé
alors on va parler de la campagne de
valérie pécresse si vous le voulez bien
qu'il sera de nouveau en meeting
vendredi au cannet c'est un fief
historique des de l'est républicain est
pas lisse parce que chez eric ciotti le
maire christian estrosi a déjà rallié la
république en marche alors il va falloir
qu'elle travaille valérie pécresse c'est
ce qu'a dit en tout cas nadine morano il
est regardé
nous passons un moment difficile le
meeting a été un très beau moment de
communion une mobilisation très forte de
nos militants de nos élus mais c'est un
exercice dans lequel valérie n'excelle
pas ils ont vu que la candidate était
enthousiaste mais que c'était un
exercice difficile pour elle un exercice
difficile pour elle valentin blé lait du
pain bénit évidemment pour la reconquête
alors évidemment il n'y a pas que nadine
morano il ya aussi eric ciotti était le
candidat le plus à droite à la primaire
des républicains qui a dit dans le
canard enchaîné c'est calme chez lui de
dire il faut se préparer à soutenir eric
zemmour au second tour dit c'est que
déjà les républicains ont déjà prévu la
vie la victoire au premier tour
contraire l'arrivée au premier tour de
l'hexagone au second face à mâcon gens
qui préparent déjà en fait le ralliement
d'une partie des républicains d'ailleurs
on a vu avec eric woerth eric woerth
commence déjà à partir d'un mac ont
quant à eux été les républicains où l'on
se scinder une partie va aller rejoindre
zemmour ce que c'est le candidat qui
peut y aller face à mâcon lui notre
parti va qu'il et prom pro macron en fan
depuis toujours comme estrosi comme
overs ont commencé déjà à rejoindre ils
vont continuer à rejoindre les
maquereaux disparités vers une
proposition de la droite
je jure sur la prestation de valérie
pécresse est là elle a dit qu'il y avait
une certaine misogynie dont dans les
critiques et qui ont pu suivre marine le
pen est une femme également et elle a
l'habitude de faire des meetings qu'en
avez-vous pensé vous même
effectivement j'étais un peu parfois mal
à l'aise face à la prestation de
l'électrique pécresse est une c'est une
évidence mais en réalité on assiste en
direct à j'allais dire
recomposition du paysage politique
encore une fois mon interlocuteur pense
être dire l'aspirateur des déçus la
public un mois je croise les électeurs
républicains qui croient plutôt dans la
canalisation de marine le pen et qui ce
dès le premier tour iront voter pour
marine le pen voilà
il est là il ya des des militants les
républicains qu'ils voteraient non
raciste rassemblement national et à eric
zemmour donc
mais non mais alors je ne dis pas que
monsieur zemmour on ne récupérera pas
des électeurs de mme pécresse je dis
aussi que moi je croise sans ma
circonscription par exemple des
électeurs républicains déçu de la
prestation de valérie pécresse je pense
déçu globalement
de leur mouvement et qui sont prêts au
premier tour parce qu'ils ont conclu
encore une fois je le répète depuis le
début comme 2e tour seuls marine le pen
est capable s'imposer
d'après les sondages et les messieurs
zemmour est loin de faire un deuxième
tour donc ils ont compris c'est une
articulation j'allais dire sérieuse
maintenant un délit que les premiers à
avoir critiqué valérie pécresse ce sont
les proches de nicolas sarkozy
qu'est ce que ça dit de ce parti
tout simplement on a été les leurs ce
qu'ils veulent gagner et voient ils sont
en train de se rendre compte qu'on était
avec valérie pécresse ils n'ont aucune
chance il avait encore un espoir ils
l'ont ils ont vu ce qui s'est passé ils
étaient à la sortie de la primaire à
plus de 20% je crois aujourd'hui ils
sont à 15% et continuer à descendre elle
a perdu trois points voilà ça va
continuer on était très bien
fini bronze c'est la campagne
présidentielle c'est fini le simple en
ce qui concerne nicolas sarkozy et son
manque de soutien à valérie pécresse
emmanuelle guerry vous pensez que
nicolas sarkozy pourrait appeler à voter
mayenne macro
tout et tout est possible au
sectionnement monsieur sarkozy pourrait
appeler à voter emmanuel macron
j'adore c'est plus
sa tasse de thé
en tout cas l'ancien président de la
république oui c'est ça c'est possible
tout à fait ouais ouais ouais ça vous a
mal entamé les oui c'est pareil je pense
est fort probable que qu'à nicolas
sarkozy finissent par se tient
maintenant surtout si valérie pécresse
continue à dépendre le grill parlant
alizés certainement l'enjeu juger ça
paraît évident ce qu'on est en train de
dire à tout le monde de tout le monde
peut le supposer
encore une fois la décision appartient à
monsieur sarkozy il est en tout cas on
peut le supposer alors on rentre on l'a
vu un il ya des défections en faveur du
parti à la reconquête en faveur du parti
des manuels macron dans quel état seront
le rnd a l'air surtout après cette
élection est ce que ce scrutin ne va pas
sonner le glas finalement de de tous les
partis traditionnels
je commence par vous valentin glennie
évidemment
c'est possible d'une certaine façon
emmanuel maintenant à d'exposer la
gauche puisque aujourd'hui le ps on voit
dans quel état ils sont même la gauche
globalement les fort probable que le rn
et les élèves terminent d'une certaine
façon comme le parti socialiste et le
parti communiste ont adressé au reste de
l'actualité à présent avec avec ce
l'actualité pour christiane taubira qui
pour l'instant n'a que 73 parrainage
elle accuse de manoeuvre politique les
manoeuvres politiciennes pardon je cite
d'entraver le résultat de la primaire
populaire et les amis de christiane
taubira était d'ailleurs hier soir
devant le conseil constitutionnel
écoutez la
comme vous le savez la collecte des 500
signatures est plus que jamais difficile
pour de nombreux candidats si je ne
parvenait pas à réunir les signatures
nécessaires le débat démocratique sur
est amputé de la parole d'une femme
d'état quand on voit nathalie arthaud
qui a ses 500 parrainages
bravo à elle c'est pas le problème mais
ce système ne va pas manifestement dans
le bon sens non et emmanuelle guerry
non
c'est un stage à dire c'est un logo un
gros problème on vient de le dire
moi je pense et j'en parle avec les
maires sûr parce que malheureusement on
ne fait pas vraiment tellement campagne
puisqu'on est aujourd'hui décines nous
allez voir les maires pour trouver les
parrainages
à quelques semaines de l'échéance
arrêtée nous on réclame demain
l'anonymat des départs ainsi je puis
dire
devant le devant le conseil
constitutionnel et ça irait beaucoup
mieux ça ne changera rien ce serait des
élus quoi qu'il arrive
et sous couvert d'anonymat il pourrait
parrainer tel ou tel candidat voilà ce
qu elle l anonymat la levée de
l'anonymat c'était pour éviter que qui
est des parrainages farfelue mais quand
on voit que même christiane taubira a du
mal à les avoir là la question de la
question est quand même ne se pose plus
peut-être pour d'autres raisons mais moi
je considère que les élus les élus en
général qu'ils soient locaux ou les élus
natation sont assez matures assez
j'allais dire en fait d'une candidature
peut-être farfelues et il irait
naturellement donné leurs pages un
candidat potentiellement sérieux
valentin velits et les émois annulé un
déplacement à la réunion pour
concrétiser ses promesses et il dit
qu'il a 450 500 promesses de parrainages
mais il reste 15 jours
c'est un véritable scandale démocratique
puisque en réalité que ce soit pour
marine le pen eric zemmour devant luc
mélenchon sont quand même des candidats
des candidats qui font bien plus que 10%
dans tous les sondages est aujourd'hui
et il ya de fortes chances que je vais
utiliser les parrainages justesse et
elle ça c'est pas normal que vous avez
cités nathalie arthaud qui elle a eu pas
de problème en fait pour avoir les
parrainages pourquoi parce qu'on était à
des pressions en pressions des partis ps
et les herbes etc mais également des
pressions des dés
dix présidents de communautés de
communes des présidents de départements
qui voire même des présidents de région
qui peuvent couper les subventions en
réalité ou menacé de couper des
subventions des petits maire
voudrait faire vivre la démocratie n'est
qu'ils ont peur tout simplement de se
faire couper les subventions pour le
leur si les couleurs citoyennes en or
lors leurs administrés et ça c'est pas
normal
alors aujourd'hui le but je pense ce
serait que fait tous ces partis en tout
cas que vraiment on dise qu'il n'y aura
pas de sanction qui n'aura pas de choses
comme ça puisque en réalité cette c'est
quelque chose de totalement
anti-démocratiques d'être empêché des
candidats comme ça de se présenter sur
sous des prétextes un peu fallacieux et
on va parler allez moi je veux juste
insiste effectivement sur un point et ça
c'est le retour du retour du terrain
nous avons ici dans laquelle et des
mères qui ont donc en charge des
communes des deux rives où marine le pen
a fait défaut après 70 % au premier tour
et au deuxième tour en 2010 est plus
tendue au directoire et
ses mers nous indique effectivement
avoir des pressions directes
subventions et quand ils ont quand ils
ont un service municipal d'un
fonctionnaire ou deux mois c'est très
difficile de refuser naturellement des
subventions notamment jédir du
département ou de le pci qui les
utilisent entoure effectivement je
rejoins mon interlocuteur alors on va
parler de la situation sanitaire il nous
reste quelques minutes ça s'améliore le
ministre de la santé a annoncé la fin du
port du masque possiblement mi mars et
ça compte bien regarder
à la mi mars si les hôpitaux sont en
état normal de fonctionnement et si la
circulation du virus est très faible
nous pourrons enlever les masques pour
les adultes et pour les enfants pour
tout ou partie des lieux fermés y
compris sans passer ça tombe bien parce
que certains à 10 évidemment que c'était
une mesure électoraliste valentin de
l'ailé qu'en pensez vous
très clairement on voit très bien la
volonté des manuels maintenant et du
gouvernement a été de lever les
restrictions petit à petit
jusqu'au moment de l'élection est pour
pour créer un enthousiasme du
gouvernement qui libérerait après des
mois et des mois si c'était maintenant
malheureusement des années de
restrictions et évidemment c'est
électoraliste et l'algérie votre
sentiment
à écouter fois très clair et vous savez
je suppose avec mes collègues députés à
l'assemblée a voté donc le mois dernier
presque un peu plus d'un mois contre le
pass sa phase finale
contre ce passé qui est une loi en fait
coercitives une loi a justifié voilà
aujourd'hui que le gouvernement
quelques semaines avant la
présidentielle décide de retirer ce se
passe axe inhalent pour en disait la
liberté aux français mais les français
ne sont pas dus par l'état français ne
sont pas dupes la somme bien de cet
enfumage
électoraliste et à mme andrée ça se
paiera ce genre de
comportement ce genre de deux manières
de faire
sont pas dupes le rassemblement national
dès que se passe avec senna est impasse
politique valentin délits sur cette
question vous êtes d'accord avec nos
rassemblement national mais très
clairement on d'ailleurs
eric zemmour à l'annoncé déjà dans son
programme qui est qui mettrait fin c'est
à ce pape vaccinale qui cite en réalité
on voudrait très bien que ça ça n'a pas
les effets escomptés et surtout c'est
une privation de liberté extrêmement
forte
nous on en est là aussi on a aussi
candidat de la liberté justement exaucé
le candidat des libertés et jeudi à
liberté de pouvoir quand même aller au
restaurant de pouvoir cc c'est quand
même
une fierté des moniales on ne sait pas
comment on peut évoluer évidemment
l'épidémie ce qu'on sait en tout cas
c'est que les enfants en primaire sont
toujours obligés de porter le masque une
réaction est très très court là-dessus
emmanuelle guerry s'il vous plaît oui
mais je suis moi concerné j'ai ma fille
de sept ans qui est donc à l'école
primaire qui est donc concernée par le
port du masque donc elle même et ses
camarades de classe s'en plaignent au
quotidien quelque chose de concret
pensez à ces enfants qui ne serait ce
qu'une paire de lunettes ce masque en
vue le candidat gelée verte et c'était
compliqué pouvoir en fait de ce pouvoir
suivre le jeu voit jouer confirme déjà
bah oui ça c'est la même chose mais là
ce sont quand même des enfants voilà
attend pas forcément tout le temps les
mots pour s'en défendre c'est vrai merci
beaucoup en tout cas merci à tous les
deux d'être d'avoir participé à ce débat
en direct dans la maquillage merci